always pleased to have dr. Patrick tang
joining us on the news our division
chief of pathology Sciences at Siddha
medicine here in Doha nice to see a
doctor it seems to me that there what
we've just played there it's a two-level
thing there's what people can do
themselves and then there is official
treatments if I can call that so if
there's no official treatment what do we
do about that is there anything on the
horizon that you that you hear about in
medical circles definitely there's no
specific treatment for a corona virus
right now people are working on many
randomized control trials in many of the
regions that are heavily affected by
Kovan 19 such as in China some of the
early results have shown that some of
the drug combinations have not worked
when they tried it on many people so
it's very important that we trust these
messages they're coming from the whu-oh
and other reputable medical authorities
that there are no specific treatment for
cope in 19 of yet and as well as
treatments we're also waiting for
vaccines and and those could be one year
down the road as well - and is this what
happened in the past with you know SARS
and MERS I sort of use those as a bit of
a yardstick sometimes where a new strain
comes along and then there's this
scramble to find something that works
certainly there are therapies that work
so giving people oxygen and supporting
them while they recover from the virus
them with their own immune system is
something that we we do right now same
thing was applied during stars and MERS
but at the same time we are also trying
to find specific drugs that might also
help those that are severely ill so
definitely during this crisis we are
trying experimental therapies but these
need to be done in a very controlled
manner in places that have designed very
well controlled trials to be able to
show whether the drug actually works or
that it might even cause harm for the
beam okay so that's working on a level
of what what doctors are trying to
create
there are also governments around the
world you know issuing tips on how
people can try to prevent spreading or
catching the disease so these are the
things we can do ourselves I think we've
got the CDC website here just for our
viewers you know talking about how it
spreads the steps you take to protect
yourself and that's sort of what I want
to get in to you with you now what
people can do in their everyday life we
know about the washing hands and we know
about the social distancing but also
start to see things about well if you do
leave the house and you come back home
what about your clothes what about your
wallet that you use to pay for your
grocery or your handbag or or anything
like that
are these all sort of risk areas which
we need to think about when we re-enter
our house certainly everything that
contacts in the external environment is
a potential source of infection but we
have to look at everything in relative
terms and and take everything in
perspective so so the things that you
mentioned are very important so social
distancing washing your hands and also
the other thing you can add is cleaning
high touch surfaces so you and mention
things like your wallet maybe your your
jacket and other things like that so
what what do you do when you actually
come home so the most important thing is
is to wash your hands or if your hands
have contacted hi touch surfaces outside
that might be contaminated or touched by
other people then it's important that
you wash your hands the things that you
bring in with you I mean there's
different recommendations from different
governments some people say that you
should clean all your packages and other
things like that but most of us don't
you know don't lick our packages or do
other things like that so I think it's
very important that you have packages or
bags or other things like that
you take your items out of there and you
may want to throw away the packaging
that might actually have it it is
actually very difficult to move boxes or
plastic bags or other things like that
so so get ready to transfer these out
into cleaner packages they're very
important and then wash your hands after
yeah so go always go back to the basics
of washing your hands dr. Tang one more
thing I want to ask you about and this
is about Musk's
you won't be able to see but I've Anya
I'm putting my mask on now which is
pretty heavy-duty and done if you can
still hear me actually it's a it's a big
fabric mask and it's got replaceable
filters inside in 99 filters I believe
they're called it makes me feel better
when I go out if I'm wearing this but
what is the or is there a definitive
word on whether this is actually helping
me or not well we all know that masks
are much more useful when they're used
on people that are sick or used by
people who are taking care of people
that are ill so the effectiveness of a
mask on a regular person that's just
going outside
it is not very high there there's many
risks and caveats so using a mask so one
would be that you might have a false
sense of security of the mask when
you're using the mask might do high risk
behaviors that you wouldn't normally do
you might be adjusting the mask all the
time because it's not comfortable and
then you end up touching your face with
your contaminated hands and and the
other thing is when you people regular
people start buying all these medical
supplies it makes it more scarce for the
people who really need it the health
care workers around the world dr.
Patrick tang always a pleasure thank you
for all your advice we do appreciate it